JESSE: I've eaten probably
a half a pound, if not more,
of pine bark in the
last three days.
But since probably
day eight, I haven't
had to have a bowel movement.
So wanted to make some
flour with my pine bark.
The flour should be a
lot easier for my body
to digest than just straight
pine bark, so I have hopes
that it will help push
everything through.
Going to have to use the rock.
Crush, crush, crush, crush.
This will be pretty good.
Nice handle up here.
I've never made flour before,
so, you know, here's--
here's to firsts.
There is consistency of it.
[bleep] stomach, man.
[sniffing]
Uh, my lower abs
are tightening up.
Or at least, like, the inside.
Ah, OK.
Ah-- yeah, that's--
that's come back a little bit.
It's like I need to
fart, but I can't.
Ah.
Ah, go away.
[groaning]
Ah.
Come on.
[breathing heavily]
Ah.
Ah, it's all--
[breathing heavily]
Lay down.
Oh.
Ah.
Ugh.
[groaning]
Shh.
Ah.
Oh.
[breathing heavily]
It's just a lot of pain.
Ah.
[groaning]
It's like someone's pulling
barbwire out of my stomach.
[breathing heavily]
[groaning]
I don't know what to do.
Ow.
[groaning]
All right.
This is-- this is too much.
Tell my brothers and
my sister I'm sorry.
I'm really sorry.
[radio beeps]
This is Jessie.
I'm-- I have to tap out.
[music playing]
[engine approaching]
[groaning]
I resent having to
go out like this.
The big, bad Green Beret gets
taken out by his stomach.